okay there's a discover check we were
assuming uh King H7 let's bring up the
analysis board while Yan returns and now
Knight G6 we were saying Rook G8 but
Anish Queen F7
and I'm going to take this
and Checkmate you oh
that's weird look at this I'm not uh
this is not my strength checkmates I'm
gonna start something I'm bad at
checkmates
check many patterns there is a video
online also where a bunch of top players
don't check it's just not my strength
it's just very difficult oh this is
beautiful wow and so this is why the
default D5 push contributes you cover
the E6 Square cover the Escape Square he
saw this what was it five six moves in
advance oh I just didn't occurs to me or
D5 takes away the E6 Square oh wow
that's a beautiful finisher
well amazing wow that's so beautiful I
must say shout out to the featured chat
I saw that uh people were hinting that
it was a beautiful finish and that's the
only way you can stumble across this
unless you're doing and you're unless
you're a genius I would never have found
this either